fantastic news the the mhra the fiercely
independent regulator
has clinically authorized the
the vaccine for for roll out the nhs
stands ready to make that happen
so from early next week we will start
the program
of vaccinating people against covert 19
here in this country
and as we know from earlier
announcements this vaccine is
effective the mhra have approved it as
clinically
safe and we have a vaccine so it's very
good news now
you mentioned the minor 70 conditions
that it needs to be stored in so this is
a challenging rollout
and the nhs in all parts of the uk
stands ready to make that happen they're
used to handling
vaccines and medicines like this with
these sorts of conditions
uh it's not easy but we've got those
plans in place and this morning i spoke
to my
uh my counterparts in the devolved
nations
uh to make sure that we are all ready to
roll out this vaccine um early next week
i'm i'm guessing hoping that might be
monday i'm sure you'll correct me if it
isn't um but minus 70. that means that
you're not going to be able to get it
from your gp
so there's going to have to be
specialist centers are they like the
nightingales are going to be
turned into specialist centers
well there'll be a combination of three
modes of delivery
the first is hospitals themselves which
of course have got facilities like this
and 50 hospitals across waiting to
receive the
vaccine you know as soon as it's
approved so that can uh now happen
and then they'll also be vaccination
centers
which will be as you say big centers
that where people can go to get
vaccinated
and they're being set up now and then
they'll also be a community rollout
including
gps and pharmacists now of course
because of the -70 storage conditions of
this
of this vaccine and they will be able to
um to support this rollout where they
have those facilities
but they'll also be there should the
astrazeneca vaccine be approved
because that doesn't have these uh cold
storage requirements
and so is uh is operationally um easier
to roll out but
i just want to thank all of the
scientists at beyond tech and
and pfizer who who are manufacturing
this
uh who we've worked so closely with and
we're the first country in the world to
have a
clinically authorized vaccine to roll
out
that's absolutely amazing and what a
relief
for so many people watching today we
know the order of people you've
told us many times who will get this
vaccine but i want to just put this to
you if i may people with learning
difficulties six times more likely to
die from
covid will they be on the list as some
of the early people to get this vaccine
yes the joint committee on vaccinations
and immunisation is the clinical
committee that advises the government
on on the priority and who gets the
vaccine in what order
they will be setting out details of that
prioritization
later this morning along with the mhra
who will set
out the clinical details behind this
vaccine and why they've taken the
decision to
authorize it so that will happen
mid-morning so that people can see all
of the details
and also that prioritization which is
set out according to
clinical need as you know we've been
supporting people who are clinically
extremely vulnerable to
covid throughout this uh throughout this
crisis
and the the jcvi will be setting that
out in detail
okay um which brings me to vaccine
passports
michael ghost says we don't need them
one of your other colleagues george
eustis says that we
will and not george you said forgive me
it was nadim zahari of course wasn't it
do we need a vaccine passport when we've
had it in order to get access to pubs
restaurants places of worship i don't
know who wherever else
it might be do we need a vaccine
passport
well that isn't part of our plan and one
of the reasons is that
while we know that this vaccine protects
you
from getting ill with kovid we don't yet
know how much it stops you transmitting
covid until we've rolled it out broadly
we'll of course be monitoring that very
carefully
and and therefore um we will
vaccinate according to protecting the
people who need
uh the protection most uh according to
those who are vulnerable from covert so
that isn't part of the plan the plan is
to get this rolled out according to the
clinical prioritization that the uh
the formal my formal advisors will set
out later this morning
so we might need a vaccine passport but
not yet is that what you're saying
it's it's not part of the plan the plan
is for the nhs to
roll out this vaccine now that we've got
it uh
and um and start that early next week
and do that according to clinical
priority
okay let me just ask you this about your
former buddy your former neighbor
apparently you gave him a gig
uh creating plastic vials for this uh
covered test kit
um tens of millions of uh plastic vials
um chatted to you over what's up uh he's
never had any experience of it
previously what's all that about
uh well there's an awful lot of people
who've come forward to
uh support the nation in our
in our battle against uh and a
constituent of mine came forward and
approached the government
and went through the the normal channels
and i'm of course i'm very pleased with
and grateful to all those who've come
forward
so i had nothing to do with this this
contract i don't have anything to do
with the signing of individual contracts
um and what i what i am though pleased
about
is the number of people who've come
forward whether it's ppe
or on the testing who've stepped up in
the nation's hour of need and so i'm
very grateful to all of them
you mentioned your steps grandfather
derek
in the house of commons yesterday he
sadly has died as a result
of covert 19 and we offer our sincere
condolences
from everyone here at sky news how has
that changed your approach to your work
well thanks for for raising it
you know i have a i have a a big and
uh complicated and loving family and
um you know losing a member of your
family is obviously
a a a big thing for anybody
and it's just made me more determined
kay you know this is a horrible disease
and i've hated seeing so many people
suffer from it
and it just really brings it home to you
when it's a member of your own family
and um you know the the
the work that we're all doing together
abiding by these rules i know that the
rules are
frustrating and i know that you can have
debates about
some of the boundary issues but the
thing about the rules is they're there
they're there not to be to push the
boundaries they're there as a
to tell us what are the limits of
behavior that is that that can keep
people safe
and it just underlines how important it
is
for people to abide by these rules and
you know this morning we've been talking
about the
amazing news on the vaccine and and that
is
the that is the hope you know help is on
its way
but we've still got to get from here to
there and we've got to keep people
safe in the meantime um
you know derek was in his 70s
and people are vulnerable to this
disease it hasn't gone away it hasn't
lessened in its potency
and it can still take people away from
everyone's
from everyone's family and it strikes
you know
it can strike anybody so we've got to
stick at it we've got to stick together
i know it's frustrating
i'm really glad that the new measures
were passed with a
three-figure majority in the house of
commons last night
and i'm uh and i ask everybody to
not only abide by the tiering rules but
respect
the personal responsibility all of us
have
to try to reduce the transmission of
this virus because we want to we
especially with the end in sight and now
that we've got this
this vaccine actually being delivered
next week yeah
you talk about uh what happened in the
house of commons yesterday you can't
really call it a victory can you i mean
so many
um mps new intake mps as well decided
that they wanted to not support the
government and apparently the prime
minister
standing in the corridor pleading with
these new mps to vote
uh in his favor i mean how very
unedifying
hardly that's what uh that's what we do
when there's what the prime minister
does
oh yes and and people you know wrestling
with their
consciences actually these are really
big decisions i i respect the
uh the decisions that people made
but actually it was a it was an
overwhelming majority a majority of 213
in favor
of this action so i'm really glad that
the house of commons has passed it
the so overwhelmingly and um
that shows to the country that we need
to all
abide by these measures uh and we need
to stick with it
let's stick with it because you know
help is on its way
we can now see the way out and we can
see that by the spring we're going to be
through this we're going to be through
this but
let's let's not let up and lose our
resolve now
let's hold hold on to it look after
ourselves
and follow those rules that as you say
the house commons passed so
uh convincingly last night and
overwhelmingly uh
and um and then we'll get through this
as safely as we can
and then you know get on the road to
recovery and
as the prime minister puts it build back
better okay out of this by the spring
um bold claims let's see if that's the
case or not i want to ask you about
scotch egg gate before i let you go
um you know it seems funny to some the
papers making fun
of it this morning but for many people
in the hospitality industry
it's very very serious they face huge
fines if they don't get this right they
don't we don't know what a substantial
meal is
and what it is and even the government
doesn't know tell me
is a scotch egg um a substantial meal
well a substantial meal is a
well-established
uh concept in hospitality yeah but what
does it mean to you
and so people of course a
scotched egg that is uh that served as a
substantial meal is a subs
that is a substantial meal um and i i
come back also to the broader point
okay which is let's not uh have a
pick at these boundary issues what we
need to do is not try to push the
boundaries we all need to take
responsibility for our own
actions by our politicians and our
politicians are giving us different
answers to a very simple question about
whether a scotch egg is a substantial
meal and you and you know do you have
one do you have two
well it just seems almost absurd why
don't you just tell us what the rules
are
and we can abide by them and then people
won't get a ten thousand pound fine
yes and okay i'm telling you what the
rules are
the rules are that a substantial meal is
a well-established principle
in hospitality uh people in the
hospitality trade
know what a substantial meal is because
it is a standard way of describing
uh the two different types of
hospitality
um those that obviously those that serve
meals and those that don't
um and so a a starter can be a
substantial meal
you can have a scotch egg as a starter
but i just want to get away
from you know this sort of the picking
up the boundaries because this a much
much bigger and more important thing
going on which is everyone has a
responsibility
to act carefully not to push at the
boundaries of these rules
but to live within these rules until we
can get
enough people vaccinated that we can
lift the rules all together
and we can all get on that's that's what
we all need to do
you can live you can push at the
boundaries which is what we do as a
nation and still live within the rules
as long as you know what the rules are
which brings me to my final question can
you have
wet pubs have to close at the moment can
you take have a takeaway delivered to a
wet pub which apparently this is a
serious question
quite a few pubs in central london are
planning to do that they're planning to
have
mcdonald's other takeaways are available
to deliver to the pubs so that
that their guests can eat those
takeaways indoors
is that allowed
we've set out very clearly the
principles
uh and in law what is and isn't expected
and if you uh if you if you break
uh that law it's set up for breaking the
law on that
for the courts yes answer my question
health secretary
let me let me ask people is their
um livelihood it it's also the law and
we passed the law in parliament and we
passed it last night
and it is for the courts to interpret in
on each
individual case uh but what i'd say is
that people should
only take them to
absolutely will enforce against these
laws okay so this is my question it's a
serious question i know you've got to go
it's really important can i eat a
takeaway
in a wet pub
the law was passed last night if people
break that law
what then they'll end up in canada in a
wet pub hey
i'm being absolutely clear with you you
don't know the role of parliament is to
pass that
i i know that it's a matter for the
courts depending on the individual
circumstances
it doesn't matter okay it doesn't matter
how many times you
interrupt me i'm going to tell you what
the answer is and the answer is
that the courts interpret the the courts
interpret the law that's set
by parliament for this country the law
has been set last night if people break
that law then it's for the courts based
on the individual circumstances
uh to determine that but there's a
bigger principle at stake
okay this is really important
what does the law say about eating a
takeaway
in a wet pub please just answer the
question
the law says that it is okay to have a
takeaway and then it is for the courts
to interpret
whether uh that is what is actually in
fact happening in each individual case
since you haven't given me an individual
case
uh and since that it hasn't i'll give
you
in soho says that they are going to
allow their uh
their clients to eat mcdonald's to be
delivered
into their pubs so that they can open it
is that acceptable or not
well i don't think it's acceptable to
try to push the boundaries of these
rules
and it's a matter for the courts to
interpret the law okay good to talk to
you i know you've got to go and
fantastic news
about the vaccine that is amazing news
thank you so much for joining us this
morning always appreciated